We've all seen the flashy intro, the catchy music, and some great special effects,...
...but in real life, a crime lab isn't anything like what you see on CSI.
This instrument on television will tell you everything...
...from someone's DNA profile to what kind of metal is in something.
Corey Winar manages the Oregon State Police crime lab in Central Point.
He says what you see on CSI can be deceiving.
This would say something like 'lipstick', which it doesn't really do.
Winar says the limitations of reality and the expectations driven by television...
...are problems he deals with all the time.
It has impacted what the expectation from our customers are from us,...
...and a lot of it is for us to educate them on what we can't even do that analysis.
The customers he's talking about are law enforcement...
...and while there is a lot of technology out there,...
...it doesn't work the way it does on the silver screen.
Not every criminal leaves a key piece of physical evidence linking them alone to the crime.
We find prints at a lot of scenes that don't necessarily match the suspect...
...or anybody else that we've been able to locate.
Keith Ostrander is a forensic technician for Medford Police.
His specialty is fingerprints.
He says, unfortunately, in real life, there's no magic machine...
...where police can scan in a print and pop out a match in five seconds.
So what it does, it actually gives a list of candidates,...
...it's in a way on-screen, we go through there and look at them and say yes or no on those candidates.